dans l'univers de beita nos péchés il ne
suffit pas d'être bourg l'utilisent pour
paraître chaque objet chaque création de
cet architecte designer perd tout sens
rien classable pour qu'on soit une
question et s'il se complaît dans la
résine de polyuréthane de fif au froid
c'est l'état qui m'a fait c'est qu'ils
s'interrogent depuis 37 ans sur l'eau
mais sa place dans le monde contemporain
péché a très peu répondu à l'invitation
de d'industriels et d'une certaine
manière
travailler en solitaire à détourner des
matériaux détournés des moyens de
fabrication
donc à partir de là à créer un monde on
peut dire un univers tout à fait
particulier avec bien sûr des objets
utiles
oh
à
c'est une exposition même très ludique
tous ces matériaux vivement colorés avec
justement tous ces personnages qui
interviennent dans des objets qui
devrait des objets sans problème sans
histoire donc tout ça donne évidemment
un caractère assez féerique sur cette
exposition plane leader du ministre ne
discutait par d'invisibles capteurs
oblige les maquettes sont aussi dans des
housses qui se gonflent et se dégonflent
consignant l'appétissante si nos
graphiques de 7,6 me reste active qui
lui est consacré 20 ans l'architecte
philosophe avons baissé au hasard le
soin de mettre la touche finale